l'entreprise supporte au prix de
transformation de produits de la réunion
surtout elle a été créée en le 18
novembre 2014 en fait cette entreprise
mal a repris parce que c'est une
entreprise qui appartenait à ma famille
pour des raisons maladie elle a dû
arrêter son activité
donc après trois mois d'inactivité
autant me suis remis retrait
l'entreprise puisque mala et daël
auparavant dans l'entreprise donc
pourtant me reprendra tôt puisque la
demande de produits les terrains
en fait nous propose des packs de piment
sous diverses formes et on à la pâte de
piments nature c'est la pâte de piments
combavas la pâte de piments gens ne
manque pas de piment cabré pas de film
en kabylie citron la pâte de piments
citron on à la pâte de piments your
engine quelquefois donc un haut niveau
de gamme de spas du commonwealth à g à
allonger jusqu'à votre ulti dit pâte de
piments acuna les achats les achats les
achats de la nasse les achats nana
citron ananas citron orange c'est le
mélange de fruits apprennent à l' orange
le citron le bénin be le calebasse le
margot margot citron
si jacques baril le caviar d'aubergine
tous les produits que nous fait céder
produits de saison
l'ouverture l'entreprise malade
récemment elle a cessé hier pour
une matinée des créateurs étude est ma
partie mal à malo vers l'entreprise dans
ce projet dont l'entourage des toujours
la salaison dans la famille est toujours
là n'est pas facile d'avoir un travail
de nos jours c'est ali lagha créé
carrément son travail et lui vivent de
ça joli joli mouvement l'a pas eu
c'est pas tous les jours mais à rose
n'est pas tous les jours
il a eu des viandes et des pas mûres
mais malgré ça m'amuse et il est
toujours là et baissent pas la tête
enfin pour l'innovation nous va dire que
presque tout le monde quand je fais des
achats d'actifs est cuit - le principe
mais a décidé de faire autrement c'est à
dire de donner aux gens le vrai goût du
produit c'est à dire c'est à dire
conserver le produit naturellement et au
moins que les pays-bas son goût mais
produit intéresse des réunionnais parce
que par rapport à nos produits anti
retrouve un peu that la culture une
culture d'avant ce tiroir connaît le
goût du produit exotique connaît aussi
la qualité sur tout